well right now our eight news now
investigators are learning the man
accused of his second fatal DUI had a
valid driver's license even after three
prior DUI convictions 8 news now
investigator David Charles was the only
reporter in court
this is the first time that I have
prosecuted someone personally for taking
a life and had them come back having
taken another life in exactly the same
way convicted again
in 2012 prosecutors did not hold back
Tuesday as 50-year-old Prentice Bates
stood before a judge again be charged in
count one the particular homicide as the
8 news now investigators first reported
Bates is accused of his second fatal DUI
prosecutors alleging he was high on
drugs when he slammed into a parked car
near Rancho in Craig last Thursday the
crash killing 40-year-old Demar Sims who
was working as a construction zone
Flagger but at this point he is entitled
to the presumption of innocence the
defense is not going to uh try this case
this morning in court Tuesday
prosecutors said Bates who had an
additional pending DUI charge from June
had a valid Nevada driver's license
allowing him to rent the car they say
was involved in his latest fatal crash
Prentice Bates on September 22nd was in
possession of a valid Nevada driver's
license with at least three prior DUI
convictions one one of which he killed
somebody in that case Bates served eight
years in prison during his sentencing
the judge ordering an interlock device
to be placed on his car after his
release people should be frightened by
the fact knowing that people like
Prentice Bates are driving around on the
same roads they're on
with valid driver's licenses that just
should not be that judge ordering baits
held without bail he is due in court
again within the next two weeks at the
Regional Justice Center I'm David charns
8 News Now
David thank you for that well the eight
news now investigators have asked the
DMV why bates's license was not revoked
after his most recent DUI in June well a
spokesperson said they were working on a
response